says oh yeah you know call call him
whenever you know he'll
he'll pick up and so i call and they get
i get put right through
and it's just warren freaking buffett on
the phone and basically he said you know
oh yeah i'm not doing anything i can
talk for as long as you want
and i just got to pick his brain for an
hour and it was insanely inspiring right
like this guy
he was exactly who you'd expect him to
be i find with a lot of these guys it's
like don't meet your heroes
and uh they're not who
he's available all day he talked to me
for an hour and a half
and he was just the nicest guy he's
exactly like he was on his
cnbc interviews showed a ton of interest
in what i was doing and like i literally
just like
grilled him for like 30 minutes
yeah he's definitely on a landline and
it was just it's always it's always
really nice when someone is what you
hoped they'd be
that's great so we'll bring it back to
gilbert but just so you know i have a
feeling the clip that you just said
about
buffett that's going to go viral um
so hopefully you're okay with that uh
and if you're not
you could tell us um all right um
you you have something